hey everyone hi hello thanks so much for
joining I'm so first of all thank you so
much for signing up for this workshop
I'm if you have not signed up and you're
crashing you're more than welcome if
there are there if there is room is
there any more in room I'm if anybody
who wants to be like kind and squeeze in
like four in a row or anything um that's
more than welcome but yeah thank you so
much for signing up and joining and uh
do you like my setup I have like two
microphones this is the first time
that's happened so I asked for a
microphone for their room because I'm
getting a little bit sick or was getting
sick or um and my throat is a little bit
sore so I can't quite project so that's
why I have a microphone and then
apparently the other microphone is for
the YouTube livestream which is really
cool so hey everyone my name is Shirley
um hopefully maybe you saw naughty and
nice talk yesterday um and then that's
naughty in the back um and she is
absolutely amazing
I think she's overqualified to be a TA
but if you have any questions during the
so I'm primarily running the workshop
and then Nadi is going to answer any
questions during the exercises or
anything she's gonna like help actually
if you want to just like you know help
answer questions that's fine too
but if you have any questions during the
exercises or anything then you're more
than welcome to ask me or Nadi and
whoever one of us look less busy so yeah
yeah I'm so I guess we can get started
cool anybody uncomfortable were with
like where they're sitting or like oh
well there's I guess that that area yeah
like if you can find a chair then you
can sit there maybe we can ask the hotel
for more chairs me me
we're going to be a fire hazard yeah so
this is the workshop slice and then if
you just go to this URL that I've
written and then um it's the very first
one so you should link that once you
link here and then the very first one so
if you can open that up and then I'm and
then you can follow along there is that
is there wait do I have a oh yeah go
bears and I'm like do I have like a
password on it or something I guess you
and I are both from Berkeley yes go
Paris um yeah so open this one up and
then I'm by the way how's everybody's
energy levels this afternoon cuz I just
say a lot at that buffet I'm scared wait
I like how after you said go bears
you pulled out a Stanford jacket yeah so
hopefully everybody feels awake so um
today I'm really excited to do this
workshop and we're going to recreate
this so this is if you um were at the if
you were at the talk yesterday this was
one of the ones that I mentioned it's
called film flowers yeah so let's see
so it's this one um and I think it's a
it's basically every single one of these
flowers are a movie you can like click
on one of them and then see the
corresponding movie and then the petals
are prendick eyes and guidance readings
colors and number of petals and size of
petals I'm and this is one of those like
fun ones that are it's like yeah it's
just kind of fun to do so today for this
workshop our goal is to recreate to
recreate this visualization and we're
not gonna put in the colors but we'll
get as far as this so like we'll be one
step away from the colors and then maybe
the stretch goal is you figure out how
to put in the colors yeah how does that
sound awesome
so yeah um I know it's right after lunch
I know that buffet was freaking amazing
I like how the second plate that I
shouldn't have because I'm like this is
really great food but uh um
if you have any questions raise your
hand interrupt me um but please do it
nicely
um and then any given point like you
know I might ask like hallo is it going
like and then just just let me know yeah
so let's get started so for this
particular workshop I'll be covering
these things so SVG paths d3
introduction to d3 so d3 scale selection
data binding enter append and finally
nesting elements and if we have some if
we have some time at the end then we can
also cover d3s enter update exit pattern
so yeah how many people have worked with
SVG before hands up just just like the
back I'm awesome
and then how many people have tried out
d3 before how brilliant ok cool so
hopefully and by the end of the day
today you'll have like a decent good
grasp of how SVG paths work and then a
good grasp of like basic core d3 at how
D 3 works so that's the goal so let's
get started here's like I sew my face
for basic SVG elements I'm so here's
actually let me back up really quickly
and say SVG elements are very similar to
HTML in that it's an XML dialect but
there's like a little bit of differences
in how you might style them or how you
might position them so here's four of
the SVG elements that use the most and
SVG elements are really great for
visualizations because it's like a like
the building blocks of SVG are like
rectangles and circles and lines and
paths I'm so for rectangles for example
you need to be able to define the XY
coordinates and the width and height to
draw a rectangle can you guys see it
fine in the back or is it too small too
small
I actually don't okay actually let me um
try and see if I can make the resolution
okay get any better no right um okay so
how about this just have it open on your
laptop because everybody has a laptop
right okay
I've been open on your laptop and then
follow along yeah cuz this uh this like
service I use if you can see like I'm
zooming in and like it's so it's great
because like it's it's scale to fit the
screen exactly as it should but it means
that I can't actually zoom so yeah so if
you can't see anything please just refer
to the slides and you have you should
have the slides open anyways because
there's links to the exercises links to
code snippets and everything so yeah so
this is all of the SVG elements I use
the most often and today we'll be
playing with the path primarily so SVG
paths I actually like asking this
question which is how many of you use
illustrator or know how to use
illustrator awesome so for those of you
that have ever used illustrator or
actually even the if you use Photoshop a
lot and there's a pen tool in Photoshop
remember how I'm when you draw a path in
Illustrator with the pen tool in
Photoshop you basically like put down
your first Anchor Point right and then
you put down and then you click again
and you put down
sorry not anchor point sorry you put
down your first point you click and you
put down your first point and then you
click and you put down your second point
and then it like draws is temporarily
line between them right and then
actually and then it kind of looks like
that and then there's like two little
anchor points that show up and then you
and then you can drag those out like
maybe the anchor point will come out to
here and maybe you'll drag the anchor
point out to here and as you drag those
two anchor points the path starts
curving like that's right
do you guys have experience with that
cool so I'm in SVG paths when you draw
curves so there's a few different um
yeah you can't really see but there's a
few different commands for SVG paths
there's the first there's mm so that's
the Move command and the way you would
use this is we might say M 0 0 and that
means move my cursor basically move to
position 0 0 where 0 is X and 0 is y so
in this case it might happen that you
said okay move me to 0 0 and then for us
to draw a curve and SVG pops the command
is C and this one I'm gonna so C goes
first anchor point a x1aa y1 and then
second anchor point and then finally
your x2 y2 and I will explain that right
now so let's say so actually let me try
and color code this this is this
and this is this and finally this is
this wow these are great markers
I just heard it ah yeah yeah is it gonna
be alright if I told ya
yeah cool so yeah did that make sense
and I can explain more like I can do
more examples so let's do it this way
so let's actually draw her so let's see
okay
let's define here is my x-axis here's my
y-axis here's my zero zero
um and then can anybody tell me why I
drew the Y going down yeah the screen
the screen always um with SVG your x
increases as you go right and your Y
increases as you go down that's how it
is for like most drawing if not all
drawing programs right I think yeah yeah
I think um so yeah let's do this
um let us draw a curve mm should we call
this maybe 10 wait that's 10 over and 10
down let's say our ending point is at
that's probably 100 so 100 and then 10
so this is our beginning actually so
this is our beginning and this is our
end and let's actually together start
draw a start writing down the SVG path
command yeah so help me with this so
for this point the way that we tell SVG
paths that we want to keep begin at this
point we say move right because we start
we always move is like you tell us VG
path like pick up the pen and drop it at
this point so we start at this point and
we say move ten ten and then let's do
this so let's say our first anchor point
is right here and let's call this 20
maybe 2000 second anchor point let's
call this an e zero and so we're going
to draw I should have done this in red
and so the final curve will look like
this
yeah so help me with this um what should
my SVG path command look like now that I
have M 1010 what should be the next come
in hey I hear you yes see
and then what's my x and y the first x
and y awesome thank you and then the
next one cool
a t0 and finally that was easy huh
that's it that's all you need to draw a
curve and that's like pretty much the
most powerful thing you can do with an
SVG path like draw a curve and that's
all I took so as long as you remember
your first starting point you move to it
and then you give it your first anchor
point your second anchor point and your
ending point and that's your curve then
let me teach you another one that I use
a lot of times which is L do you guys
want to guess what L is yeah
line two I'm gonna fit that down here
and that one is also just thanks why
it's very straightforward so basically
that one is wherever it basically says
wherever um
wherever your cursor is right now do not
pick up your pen or basically wherever
your pen is do not pick up your pen and
just draw a straight line there so
basically this is your ending point so
if let me see so then I guess I will now
just keep calling any but I'm gonna use
red for my ending points so this is
basically an ending point so let's do
hmm
shall we try doing that uh the cherry
ball blossom petal from yesterday are
you guys interested in that we'll go
through that together because because
the goal is for you to make your own
cuddles so once we figure out how to do
the cherry blossom petal then I'm going
to give you guys about 30 minutes to try
and come up with three petals of your
own I'm and that's why you should also
have pens and paper right next to you
because I found that um it's it actually
really helps if you can like write out
for yourself like all of the different
paths as you're coding along so let's
start out with this
uh-huh let's start out with this time
let's do like huh here's my eggs here's
my Y let's start up huh hold on oh wait
I don't know I shouldn't do it that way
okay let's do this
you know that here's my zero zero here
is my a hundred zero here's my zero a
hundred and then how did I draw my pedal
cool okay
I am torn oh well we'll do it this way
okay so let's draw a petal that looks
something like this and then we're gonna
figure this out together so very first
point this probably looks like 50 zero
right so what's my first command M and
then 50 zero right okay now we have
let's figure out all the points for this
one okay this one let's see this looks
like 75 75 and then what my Y would be a
hundred right great right okay yeah I'm
pretty bad at math so you need to
correct me okay so many five a hundred
actually let me do it with the right
colors then first Anchor Point is blue
okay so we're gonna just like
guesstimate cuz obviously like we can't
quite figure it out right so guesstimate
for me what that anchor point might be
eighty and then this one thirty yeah
there's like no wrong answer it's just
like the pedo might look a little bit
different from that is all yeah I'm then
second anchor point oh it's probably it
probably should be eighty right huh
should we try 90 and then the why
somebody
and so now it should be the command is
what should the command be now we're
drawing from here to here now see 80 30
yeah cool 75 100 I'm just to make sure
I'm writing big enough for the bath
right can you guys see you in the back
this is all right no bigger okay I'll
start writing bigger okay I know right
here what should this be 50
16:56 t-55 wait Hana well then remember
remember that this is a hundred
fifty-five would be like really yeah
sooo 65 you guys want to do 65 we're
gonna put this all in the computer soon
just to see what it looks like by the
way yes so let's do that so I'm gonna
try and write bigger is this B is that
good in the back okay um all right cool
so now again another line thank you
another line twenty-five and a hundred
and finally another curve back remember
this time around we're trying to curve
this way so our first anchor point is
actually over here and then our second
anchor point is over here so let's do
that so this one I heard 10 just now ten
seventy cool then I'm getting confused
with my clothes okay 2020 right 2030
yeah so that's a what what do I do now
see see ten seventy twenty thirty and
then we end here right fifty oh wait
that's a red so this is this point is
both our beginning and our end
so 50 zero that's it there anybody put
in the numbers and then it's like really
weird looking
oh and a final note if I you can put in
Z and Z just means closed path
yeah let's try putting that in you're
gonna have to read it to me because I
can't see it okay we start with it was M
50 zero right and then see what was C a
30 oh yeah right what oh really
wait wait I don't
okay I don't know oh there we go
wait humming oops cool thank you
does that help I'll try that in a little
bit okay
oh I forgot to mention click here for
started code and then I'm and let me
actually go through this is like a
little bit of an online editor that a
lot of the d3 community uses it's called
block builder org and then all you need
to do is sign in with your github so
where I have my little picture um it
should have a login for you I'm login
with your github hmm and then I just
fork my starter code for kit for
yourself so that you can like start
saving it for yourself and then it's
pretty straightforward um it live
updates um and then the one that I like
using the most is a that little oh you
can't see it on
and let's see
okay so I typically like hitting this
one so that like the editor is right by
the preview section and I think for now
that's all you need to know I think and
then I'm for that piece of code and you
can this is basically my original code
for the flower petal and then we're
gonna put in another one right now and
then I should have yeah huh oh thank you
ninety seventy seventy-five a hundred
and then fifty sixty five Oh do you see
it showing up right there and then the
next one is another l/100 thank you
and ten seventy twenty thirty thank you
well how does it feel it's just like
it's a little bit like narrow huh I like
it okay cool okay
was that fun was that fun with friends
okay all right so what Mike Mike look it
actually is pretty good right now yeah
yeah yep
okay so we're moving on and we're going
to cover two things before we break off
for an exercise again and we're gonna
cover scales and we're gonna cover a
selection and data binding so from now
on we're actually covering a d3
functionality so I guess before we get
going
um I guess let's talk about d3 a little
bit so I'm guessing everybody in here
has heard of c3 and a lot of you have
tried T 3 I'm so for reference here is
the d3 website and here is the
documentation and I tend to go to the
API reference all the time and which I
have to admit is like really humongous
and kind of intimidating and just
because there are so many different
modules that have like so many different
things that you can do so my goal for
today is that hopefully I will cover
enough of the basics that you feel or
right going through the reference we'll
see um but for now the first thing we're
going to talk about is this one right
here with the scales and then we're
going to talk about selections which is
like the one right after that
yeah see okay so let's start out with
the scales does anybody want to guess
what skills are good for before we start
Thanks Thanks and okay I guess I guess I
did walk myself into that one um thanks
okay so um I don't know if I should be
standing up or send us okay so this is
what a very typical d3 scale looks like
so one of the one of the most basic ones
is scale linear which just means that
I'm with your domain you have an input
your domain and you have an output your
range and it is basically a one-to-one
mapping so it's a linear one-to-one
mapping between your input and your
output and there's a few others that
I'll mention uh further down the line
but for now like let's just use scale
linearize our example and so the way
that I like to think about scales is
like I'm sure you've done a lot of
skills and like math class back when you
were in school or maybe even though I
don't know I'm but like I guess when I
was um the way that I like to think
about scales in the sense of d3 in terms
of data visualization is that we use
scales to map from the input data to the
display and what I mean by that is
oftentimes in data visualization we
might have data set that's like you know
there's the date and there's some sort
of a value let's take for example you
know average city temperature across a
year or something and maybe you want to
put that as a scatterplot or like a line
chart or something as your visualization
and so in that case you might think of
it as your x-axis is your time to like
the date across
say a year and your y-axis might be say
the temperature across time and so in
that case your domain would be the date
or the time and that date you can map it
to the x axis the x value and that's
your output so your domain in that case
is the date and I'm your range your
output is the x value and then me you
have another one that your temperature
is the domain so your input and your
output is the Y value and maybe for
whatever reason you also decide to map
some other data attribute to opacity etc
etc so in data visualization we think of
the input the domain as the data
attribute and we think of it as we're
trying to map the data to something on
the screen so let's take for example
some of these things um so I just drew
something like I just wrote down some
things I'm so for example maybe your
domain is your minimum is zero and your
maximum is 100 and your range your
minimum is zero and your maximum is one
so if you put input zero you'll get back
zero if you input 20 you'll get back to
zero point two if you input 75 you'll
get 0.75 a hundred and you get one or
like maybe for this example and maybe
you want to do something like your data
has a min and Max of 0 to 100 and then
maybe for your range you want to do 500
is your minimum like you want to map
your 0 to 500 and you want to map your
100 to 0
um and the reason why this might be
something you want to do and the reason
why we use scales so often in d3 and in
data visualization is because this work
[Applause]
whoa cool
who wants this if not I'm just looking
at here okay thanks for taking them okay
so the reason why we might want to do
something like the input being zero 100
and the output being five hundred and
zero it's because maybe sometimes you'll
have say maybe this is your temperature
let's say in Fahrenheit cuz there's that
would be really shitty if your city goes
to 100 Celsius so let's do Fahrenheit
there's my mic still okay back there
okay um and then maybe this is your Y
this is your Y value which means that
let's say this is your screen
which means that this should be your
zero zero and this is your zero five
hundred so then that means that for what
we're trying to do we're saying okay if
you know one of these days the sari
temperature is zero then we will want to
map it to 500 so for example what the
exact for that what we have is like
maybe the first day is 0 so we map it to
here and then the next day we have 20 so
we map it here and the next one is 50
and it's 250 here and it's so many five
so it's about right here 125 on the
screen and then a hundred is here and
that's just nice because so this was a
zero degrees one and this was the twenty
degrees one and this is the fifty
degrees one this is 75 degrees and this
is a hundred degrees and this was nice
because like without that scale maybe
you will have had to do something like
okay so it's zero degrees but then like
we need to or it's zero degrees but then
like you know we need to like put it all
the way down here so like you have to do
like the calculation yourself of like
you know inverting and inverting the
things for the screen because like Y
axis goes down like that but now if you
have a scale you just say okay mat money
like mat my minimum two down here I'm at
my maximum I'm to right here and so it's
just like you don't even need to do with
the math yourself so scales is like the
way I like to think about it is it does
all the math I don't want to do for me
to put things onto the screen
so this is what I'm the code might look
like for a scale again a little bit
small so follow along on your screen I'm
so I have some I have some there's just
kind of fake data but um so maybe I have
a I say I want a screen height or I want
a height of 600 as in like I might I
want my visualization to fit into you
know a height of 600 pixels let's say
and then let's say I have a data set and
maybe it's something like it has a date
attribute and the temperature attribute
and then here and then maybe I only
listed out two but like maybe there's
like you know 50 or a hundred of them or
something like that or like 200 points
data points however many there is and
all I have to do is say D 3 dot min pass
in my data array and um give me back the
minimum date D 3 max give me back my
maximum day
is that pretty straightforward take in
this data array and give me back
whatever the minimum date is and
whatever the maximum date is really
straightforward right cuz you guys all
do JavaScript right wait yeah right
sorry sometimes so I've taught a lot of
work and sometimes if you teach data
visualization workshops sometimes the
audience are like data scientists or
designers and sometimes they won't know
they won't have like coding much and
like beforehand so like sometimes I
can't like sometimes I have to explain
like JavaScript concepts and stuff to
them so like sometimes so ask me what
this arrow is like what the fat arrow is
and all of that so just make sure
everybody is like perfectly good with it
like fat arrow and all of the syntax is
okay yeah cool okay so the mathematics
is really straightforward um there's
another one um there's a another d3
functionality that's like really useful
and it's called d3 extent and what
extent does is it gives back and you
tell it what attribute essentially like
you tell it like what you want them in a
massive and then it returns that in an
array so like here you're the same d3
that extent paths in the data array and
then you say okay out of that data array
and for each of the data objects I'm
give me back the data the date attribute
and then d3 will give it back to you as
an array of men and Macs and that's cool
because um you want to pass the the
domain d3 is dot domain takes in an
array of min and Max so I'm in this case
it's a where we're basically taking the
min and Max from here and passing it
into the domain but um you could also
have just put in like I called this
extent here right we could have just a
dot domain extent and that would be the
exact same thing
and then of course here what I'm doing
is saying the range is I want to map the
minimum to height so like I want to map
the minimum to the bottom of that
visualization and I want to map the max
to zero which is like you know basically
the top of the visualization
alternatively I could have like you know
giving it some padding or something and
be like okay I wanted to map it map the
top to like you know 20 or something
like that but that's that that's that's
how I commonly use scales I'm and some
of those Oh before I go on how does that
sound quite straightforward right yeah
no confusion okay cuz you're going to
use scales later in an exercise so if
you have questions you should ask them
now okay okay so here are some of the
scales I use the most often and I use
scale linear which is like basically
like a sounds of linear um a linear
mapping from the domain to the range and
I also use scale log a lot so that's a
logarithmic mapping yeah from the domain
to the range so um
scale time is really great for dates so
you put in so for that one the input
needs to be a JavaScript date object and
then you can the range could be anything
the range could be like usually the
range is actually the range should be
numbers um and so that one's really
helpful especially if you have like for
example an x-axis again that's like the
input the data input is date objects and
then you want to like map it to your
x-axis and then the there's some scales
for ordinal scales so um the previous
three are the continuous skills that I
use the most often I mean for ordinal
ordinal just means that your data might
be categorical so instead of categoric
categorical and has an order
so whereas continuous could be like 0 1
2 3 or like you know 0
0.1 0.2 like it's it's a continuous
scale ordinal could be something like mm
something categorical Nadi what's a good
ordinal scale example I'm gonna call on
you thank you I really like was it I
couldn't remember one thank you huh we
did yeah yes this is good one
uh yeah t-shirt sizes yeah and you being
categorical and you being discreet you
it's been--it's it's kind of hard
thinking up here sorry what orders
what's the discrete one that doesn't
have order no no I mean what's it called
I can't remember like scale cuz it
because so okay okay okay thank you um
yeah those were good ones okay so scale
band um for that one
let's see d3 so here is um the reference
for a d3 scale and so some of the ones I
mentioned so there's continuous and you
can have linear power log identity time
sorry the order know once I mentioned
just now was a sub and it's like
basically I'm what happens is for so
each of these blue like boxes are
basically a cat like a like this could
be Monday Tuesday Wednesday so like your
domain is like Monday Tuesday Wednesday
or you know
medium/large and then your range will be
like it will literally calculate for you
and so this first box should start at 10
pixels and the next one should start at
like 30 pixels and then 40 pixels or
something like that you can just set you
can tell it I want the padding between
each of these boxes to be 10 pixels or
something and then like it will
calculate all of that for you it's
really nice um so yeah so it looks like
it looks like so this is like d3 scale
band and you can say my domain and you
can say the range that it should take up
so like maybe here it's like the domain
was the three the three things and maybe
you're right yeah yeah she says that
really nicely so your range maybe this
was like zero to 600 or something like
that and then maybe I like told it that
the padding's were ten each and they
will calculate the starting and ending
point essentially or sorry it would
calculate for you yeah it would
calculate for you the start and end for
each of the domains that you put in the
categorical domains that you put in so
some really nice functionality in here
and that you can check out if you have
the time but uh yes so those are the
ones that I use the most often yep
okay and so we're gonna so that's the
end of scales yeah yeah skew order no
it's not a thing is it not great wait oh
my god it's a thing oh my god Nadia I
told you you should teach this workshop
yesterday I told that everybody that's
not he's teaching this workshop thank
you I learned something actually so it
was actually I think I remember it being
in v3 and then when they went to v4 I
think I just like didn't find it like I
think I just like always just went
straight here or something and like
thought that he took out ordinal like I
thought he took out scale or doe so yeah
yeah I mean really there's scale orders
all hope so
oh yeah and then this is the colors that
Nadia is talking about so you can have
yeah so you can input usually it assumes
we give in the number T in the range
serial ones yeah so assumes like you
give it some number between 0 1 and it
will give you return you a color just
really nice cool
let's move on okay so we're gonna get
into D 3 D 3 now I'm so let's start with
selection and data and let's start out
with this piece of code so this piece of
code basically draws this very ugly bar
chart
and so let's talk about how it's doing
that now let's talk about first of all
here's our SVG and there are five
rectangle elements in there and here
we're saying okay d3 can you go and
select all of the rectangle elements
that you find that you find in this Dom
this document so select all the records
and rectangle elements that exist in
which case it will go and select all
five of these rectangle elements because
that's what's in the Dom right now and
if you actually console.log what d3 does
select our rectangle returns this is
what it looks like and this is what this
is how D 3 represents its selections
underneath the hood and in a bit we'll
play with this and then I'll ask you
guys to like also a lot of things and
then I'm but for now what you need to
know is that underneath the hood at d3
selection is basically an array of a
race weight it's a it basically wraps
all of their Dom elements into an array
that you can then do like a bunch of
operations on and then here we say dot
data and we pass in our data set and our
data set always has to be an array it
can be an array of numbers it can be an
array of you know strings it can be an
array of objects but it always always
has to be an array and that's just
because um this is what's happening
underneath the hood so when you do dot
data when you bind data what diri is
essentially doing is it's saying okay
we've just selected all of these
rectangle L events and now I've been
given this data set this array of data
we're going to map them one-to-one so
here was the date
right like this is the data and it's a
hundred 250 175 200 120 and here's all
of the rectangle elements that Gaara
selected so d3 underneath the hood when
you do data just says okay 100 goes so
the first data element goes to the first
da first rectangle element second one to
the second third one to the third fourth
one to the fourth etc that's why both of
them like that's why the the Dom
selection the rectangle selection is in
the array underneath the hood and that's
why the data that are you passing needs
to be in the ring because it's gonna do
that one-to-one mapping and again this
is what I'm it looks like underneath the
hood so if you go and now console.log
what d3 select all dot data returns this
is what it returns so now here's the
interesting thing
how does d3 bind data and so it
literally is putting in an for it's it's
literally putting into the rect element
like this attribute underscore
underscore data underscore underscore
one twenty and so if you open up any of
the previous rectangles you'll see that
if you open up the first rectangle it
will have underscore underscore data 100
and this one will say 250 175 200 and
that's how later on when we talk about
how to use the data that's been bound
and that's how D 3 is getting the data
that's been bound to the element and
using that so let me show you what I
mean by that so now that we've bound
data to the elements we are going we
want to say so right now we're doing
attribute X attribute Y attribute with
and attribute hi and that's how you draw
a rectangle
[Laughter]
so yeah so I attribute X Y width and
height um and so essentially what's
happening here is we're looping through
each of the rectangles in the selection
and we get passed in a data and then
index so you can see here for example
for the X attribute I'm getting passed
in a D and then I and that D is that
data that got bound to that element so a
little tiny little thing that's what
happens if I console.log the index the
data and the element itself
so let me try and see if I can walk us
through it okay let's do this let's walk
through the XY with height attributes
together so we have data a hundred we
have data 250 we have 175 200 and 120
okay and then we have rectangles 1 2 3 4
5 and let's together calculate what our
X Y width height is for each of the
rectangles yeah okay so help me here I'm
essential so okay so X is supposed to be
I times and I think wrecked with I
define us thank you
wrecked with is equal to 100 so wrecked
with I just realized you guys in the
back can't see this huh
okay uh okay all right bigger okay so
for the first rectangle
what's my eggs thank you
why is height oh cool wait on a height -
- D wait but what's my D yeah yeah hey
hold on actually let me do this really
quickly sue D is equal to 100 sorry you
guys in the back I is equal to 0 D let's
say D is 250 for the second one right
and then this is 175 200 120
okay so what's why what's why for my
first one
thank you and then what is w for my
first one Oh
thank you and then height is high with
deep
so do you would be a 100 cool okay all
right let's do X for this one is thank
you
100 y is 600 - my data was my data 350
my width is the same is a hundred okay
we don't have to do with because it's
the same every time
hi cool
we'll do the third one and then and then
we'll move on because I'm pretty sure
you guys got the idea right yeah so eggs
thank you why 600 minus 175 five thank
you
and then hikes five seven five cool so
did that help
that's essentially what d3 is doing
underneath the hood because I'm it just
basically for each of the attributes um
it executes the function that I passed
in given the data and the index
so here I want you guys to take like ten
minutes and I'm I believe Oh fun
do I not have oil mmm I don't have to
code for this one
okay give me like a minute to try and
find that block or sorry about that code
so that you can play with it actually
[Music]
No
No
okay so now try refreshing
then go to this link so it should be
right after this slide there will be
this link and open it up and that will
be that will be the bar chart this ugly
bar chart and then what I want you to do
is take five to ten minutes I'm open up
your dev console and just like try you
know like comment out pieces and then
just console.log for example just
console.log direct down here and then
try looking at what that outputs so here
for example when i console.log just the
d3 selection you can see if I open up
groups it gives me this array of
rectangles and those are actually
rectangles in the DOM and then for
example if I uncomment the dot data part
then the array of if you go on their
groups you see that array and if you
open up these rectangles all the way at
the bottom you'll see the underscore
underscore data that's bound right here
and that's how D 3 is quote-unquote
binding the data to your selection of
Dom elements and that's how underneath
the hood d3 is basically when they loops
through the dom elements to you know
apply your function to like you know if
you want to set X attributes or Y
attributes and all of that that's where
it's getting the data from that you
found so let's give ourselves five
minutes to just go through this code and
you know common things out console.log
things just so that you can get a little
bit of an intuitive understanding try to
like you know um I'll all socially just
trying to put like for example in terms
instead of like doing return items with
or something in chili just doing zero or
seeing something and like seeing what
happens like play around with what the
functions return so you can kind of you
can get a intuitive feeling of what's
happening you know if you want to like
do it with your table partners and then
like you guys can kind of explore I
think the two most important things is
understanding what each of these
functions return or sorry each of these
lines return and number two and playing
around with what each of these functions
return for each of the attributes and
how that affects the overall
visualization cool let's go on to 320
particular moment there is no rectangle
elements so it selects nothing zero
answer is an empty selection so how are
those bars those five blue bars even
appearing and the answer is that part
that's the magic that's what I like to
call a d3 is black magic
so those three and those three are not
functions yeah those three functions
that are chained together the dot data
entered append those three together are
what creates those rectangle elements
that you saw earlier so let's go into
how that's working so first of all we
have the function data and you saw like
if you saw previously that dot data what
it did was it looks at the selection the
d3 selection and then compares it to the
data that we pass in right so previously
I have five rectangular elements and
they have five data elements and then
was able to just kind of one-to-one map
each of them but this time around
as you can see no d3 is like well wait I
have 0 rectangle elements so it's like
completely empty over here and I have 5
data elements on this side and d3 goes
oh okay so for me to be able to sync
that like I need to be able to match
them up one-to-one so for that to be
able to happen I need 5 rectangles to
match the data right super
straightforward and so then it will
return that imp like that data will
return that information and then we'll
say ok you know to have the data and the
rectangle is the tablet data and the Dom
be in sync we need to create five new
rectangle elements and then and then da
enter will go and say okay I'm dot enter
we'll say okay so we need five new
rectangles put in place holders and bind
that data and finally that append will
say okay create a rectangle element for
every one of those placeholders that's
the three functions I'm that's being
chained together and that's what's
happening for each of those functions
that's it that's how that's how those uh
rectangles get made super
straightforward right like it's like
that was it I'm and I always forget
actually how like quick this explanation
is so do you guys want to learn how to
do update and actually also yeah awesome
and originally I didn't have it India
India plans but so to follow along for
that one go back to my website or like
the slides the slides calm / early woo
and go to this slide this set of slides
called a front-end masters d3 v4 and
open that up
and so I'm gonna really quickly go to
the section that's a update and exiting
here which I'll tell you in a little bit
what slide number that is because I feel
like this is actually the fun part did
anybody's good - oh there we go
okay so update and exit is slide 25 I
should start with slide 26 and yeah so
um
just now we covered enter a pen which as
you can guess and what it does is it
helps us create Dom elements that don't
yet exist based on the data we pass in
right so when when a user may be first
when when I'm when someone you know
first gets to our visualization like
when we first load a web page and we
start our visualization it might be that
like we just need to create a bunch of
elements like a bunch of bars a bunch of
rectangles or something like that
because they're coming into the web page
for the very first time
obviously the Dom is going to be empty
so then um we're going to be entering
and appending a lot of rectangle
elements but let's say after that uh
maybe you have like a you know a
real-time visualization or something
like that and maybe that real-time
visualization is a series of bar charts
and then every let's say minute you know
it updates or something like that so um
in that case maybe some of the bars have
to get exited like maybe some of the
bars have to be removed from the table
maybe some of the bars need to be
updated and maybe some new bars will
happen and it needs to be entered and
and so how do we do that and that's what
d3 Center update exit pattern takes care
of so that enter update exit is so that
we can go from one state to the next and
update accordingly so the way that it
works
yes I said 26 okay I think I sing so I'm
oh yeah this is a pretty good example so
the reason why we have the enter update
exit paradigm is this thing called
object constancy because you might have
in the data set like for example this
one is I guess top states by H bracket
and you know it says Florida and
Pennsylvania West Virginia etc and when
I change the data the underlying data
so this one is 65 years and older
actually this data set is always fun cuz
like Florida is like far above the
others in terms of like 65 years old or
older because like Florida has a lot of
we retire people and let's see like you
know maybe let's see what under five
years like which states have the most
haulers actually yeah I don't know who
that would be
apparently it's Utah Wow are you are you
from there okay that makes sense but did
you guys see also see what happened I
guess it's a little bit hard to like
okay let me switch back see 61 do you
see how like you know they there was an
animation there was a transition like it
you know it went from like because
Florida is no longer you know in the top
10 so it like got pushed down and then
there's a bunch of new ones that that
appeared and there's that so that you
can see some of them move down some of
them move up um let's try this
I do see that some of them remain on the
screen some of them do you see how some
of them are remaining some of them might
get updated and some of them get removed
cool yeah and so this is the concept of
object constancy that like for example
if you have Florida and Florida you know
drops like say all the way out of the
age bracket like all the way out of this
visualization and then you want to be
able to show that between one state and
the next like you don't want just like
you know like this is Florida and then
suddenly it's Arkansas but like you
don't you don't get that like
consistency between the first state and
the next and I think and I shoot that
okay so to do that I'm the secret of
being able to map being able to kind of
maintain that across different data
states from one data set to the next is
this key function so up until now for
the dot data function we pass in a data
array right and I was it all we did was
pass in a data array now what we can do
is pass in this thing called a key
function and when a key function does is
controls which data which datum is
assigned to which element and so for the
key function we always always want to
return whatever is the ID of that data
datum and so that it can get assigned to
route the right Dom element so let's
take this for example let's say for
example that this is what's currently on
their screen so let's say for example
that we've already created our first set
of rectangles and this is actually
what's currently on the screen and
here's all of the data that's already
been found right this is actually our
previous data set now 101 250 175 200
and let's pretend for now that this is
also our data this data that's been
found is also our key
and then now let's look at the next data
set this to 31:20 the first thing you
can notice is that there's now six
elements instead of the fight
so what da Deena does is the first thing
it calculates is it calculates the
update selection and it says oh hey in
the new data set there's 120 and 250 and
that's also in the current selection of
rectangles so that must mean that these
two rectangles match the data so they'll
remain on the screen this is our update
selection remember that term update
selection update selection is the
selected and selection of rectangles or
a selection of elements that will remain
on the screen and then d3 will say okay
now let's figure out what's extra in the
data the new data set that's not in the
rectangle elements on their screen and
it says oh it's these ones to 3301 4575
none of that is over here in the
rectangle elements and so I would say
okay I need to be able to create four
rectangles to match the data and that's
the enter selection and finally that
data will say what are the rectangle
elements that are that do not exist in
the data and that's the 100 the 175 and
the 200 and so d3 will say okay this is
the exit selection and these are the
rectangles that we need to get rid of
these are the three rectangles that we
need to get rid of so that we can match
the new data set oh yeah so enter update
exit selection now that we have that oh
this is where I show you what console
logging it looks like so what this whole
thing returns is this so this is your
enter selection the enter placeholders
here is the exit selection the three
rectangle laments that were supposed to
remove and then here is the
- this is the update selection the -
rectangle elements that can remain on
the screen so if you if you console.log
right here oh sorry this bar is right
here that's what it looks like
underneath the hood the enter selection
the enter placeholders exit selection
and update selection and then we want to
save that into a variable in this case I
call it bars so that right here I can
say bars dot exit and that gets me in
that exit selection and then take that
exit selection and remove them from the
screen that gets rid of all of the
rectangle elements that aren't in the
new data that removes them from the Dom
next this should look this part should
look familiar
right this bars that enter the append
right that's exactly the same as before
and then that basically will say I get
the enter selection for each of those
four rectangle elements append or sorry
for each of those four placeholders
append a rectangle and then we want to
set the attributes with and Stroke and
for the enter selection I like to chain
the attribute attributes that don't
depend on data so like if you can see in
here it's just a rectangle with and the
stroke because neither of these are
dependent on like it will not change no
matter what the new data set is and
finally here um we basically say give me
give me the enter selection as well as
the update selection so the bars one is
the update selection so combines the two
selections the enter and update
selections into one and that's
essentially basically what is what
should be on the screen for the new data
set and then
and then calculate the XY height and
fill for the enter and update selection
basically update the attributes that are
based on the data for the enter and
update selection and that's it so
actually with these few lines of code
you can actually um actually with these
few lines of a code you can actually
have that same effect that we looked at
earlier with the
age population oh yeah the only thing
that we're missing with this one is um
we just how don't have the line for
animation and that land line for
animation is just like one line um but
this will take care of drawing all the
rectangles and updating them on any data
change isn't that really cool that it's
like only like what that's like 15 lines
or something and then takes care of like
basically all of the animations and
transitions that you saw earlier yeah
that's all you need
that's t3 that's the core of t3 cool um
so it is 340 woo okay so is 340 so um
this is the thing that I want to do next
I'm kind of pretty excited for this one
so I'm go back to go back to the
workshop slides and what we're going to
do is turn the petals that you created
earlier into a flower are you excited
I'm pretty excited um so um here's what
we're going to do um I'm
I click on that starter coat and this is
the same movie data that I use in my
visualization and I've already kind of
like I've what's the word I cleaned it a
little bit for you um so use this movie
data and you can say you can see there's
like data for the rating the IMDB rating
and the number of votes the title the
parental guidence rating etc um so
here's the three things that you want to
do and these here's the mapping so the
type of petal is your parental guidance
reading the size of the flower is IMDB
rating out of 10 and the number of
petals is the number of IMDB ratings so
I've created the scales for you in this
starter code right here so what you have
to do is figure out your domains for the
size and the number of petals and then
here's basically the path lookup so like
I just say the these are the parental
guidence ratings and you just need to
add in three more petal paths to right
here does that make sense and then add
three in there and then right down here
um I've given you instructions I've also
given you instructions right here and
let's do this for about let's try until
four I'm tentatively and then we can go
through the solutions together um and do
this with your table partners
oh and I four and I forgot to mention
for this one um you don't eat the update
exit all you need is the scales data
enter a pen
um so for this one all you need to do is
take the data and create the petals you
are amazing
oh and I will not be offended at all if
you want to click on the complete code
and then take a look at this like so
this is the complete code um but if
you're going to look at the complete
code I would urge you to not copy and
paste things over for like rather like
type it out yourself
like oh okay um I'm just like have a
side-by-side type it out yourself and
try and figure out what each line is
doing and like try and solve that with
your table partners um and then the hint
I give you is that you need to use SVG
transforms translate rotate and scale
functions to do to be able to get all
the petals but you should end up with
something like that Bunyan yep awesome
good luck well there we go yeah how did
that go
they just go from my zero to sixty
really fast on you know okay so how many
people were able to get a flower awesome
Nadi you don't count um but thank you so
shall we go through it together
awesome okay
so everybody's gonna help me okay let's
get started
so first let's set the domain for scales
and we agreed that there were two scales
so the size scale is with the rating
right and then the number of petals
scale is with number of votes so let's
use c3 that extent like we talked about
earlier so let's call that const size
extent it's equal to t3 extent and we
pass in the movies data and then we use
d dot rating you can console.log of that
size extent and then cost let's do the
same thing for numb petal so let's say
numb pedalos extent is equal to t3 dot
can you guys see it in the back or do
you should we turn off the lights with
that hope in the back were yeah now we
need to figure out how to turn off the
lights
oh you can see it okay okay i'm t3d
extant movies and then this time we use
devotees lets console.log that to known
petals extent inspect element here hold
on i'll move it out of way
awesome so the minimum that we have is
five point six for rating out of 10 and
the maximum is that Wow
I know which movie is out of 10 out of
10 and then the number of votes minimum
is 16,000 maximum is 1.6 million okay so
far so good yeah so we figure out the
min and Max domain for both of the
skills and now we have to set the skills
sure sorry set domain on skills and that
would be the size scale so the size
skill that we've defined up above right
here so you can see the size scale is a
scale linear with a range of 0.1 to 1
and then the numpad or scale is scale
quantized and I don't know if anybody
looked it up but scale quantized is this
super useful thing that takes a
continuous and and continuous domain and
maps it to a discrete range so what that
means is if you think about it number of
votes I'm just now you saw the number of
votes is like 16,000 oh here you guys
can from 16,000 to sit 1.6 million right
so that's like a continuous number
that's our domain but number of petals
we want that to be discrete we want that
to be 5 petals 6 petals seventh petal
eight petal nine petal etc so scale
quantized will help us will help us map
that continuous 16,000 and to a discrete
number of petals and that's what scale
quantized is doing so we said size skill
that domain is size extent and then num
it'll scale domain is num petals extent
yeah now that we have the domain figure
it out
let's just make the petal data for just
the first movie and so first of all
let's figure out the number of petals
for that first movie and so we're using
numb paddle scale and thank you so much
thank you so much for pointing it out
because uh there was actually a bug in
this version in the complete version
where I forgot to use that vote so let
me so number the number of non petal
scale and then we just pass ending the
the number that so we just pass in the
number of votes for the first movie
right
so that would look like movie first
movie dot votes so number of votes for
the first movie a movies movies okay
let's call so log that and see how much
that is so movies zero dot that's
namitha petals and cool so it's three
hundred fifty four thousand and we're
going to make six petals here
wait
so far so good
okay now that we've figured out the
number of petals for our first movie we
now need to create our data array right
so we want so basically we want to
create five petals so that's five paths
and path elements right we're sorry we
want to make six petals so that's six
data elements in our array right and so
you can do this a number of ways but the
lot of way that I like to do is I like
to use lodash pass in the metals which
is six and that just gives me the index
I'm so and this low dash dot x all it
does is you pass in a integer and it
just does of four loops that number of
times and I think you can also just do
for loops you know that number of times
whatever that you're happy with I like
using underscore or low - times
underscore times numbers and then for
each of the petals
we want to do we want three things right
so for each of the petals I'm actually
I'm paying me I'll just comment it for
each of the petals to draw them the
first thing we need to know is the
rotation of the petal and the second
thing is we need to know the type of
pedal or the petal at the path of the
petal right so the the three different
petals that you guys made earlier we
need to know which one we're using and
so that's parental guidance ratings and
finally um we want to use we want to
know the size of the petals the size of
the flowers so that is size of petals
and that's we're using the IMDB ratings
okay which means that what we want to do
is first of all the rotation is um
basically you want to rotate it so SVG's
rotate takes degrees so anywhere between
0 to 360 degrees so our rotation should
be our index out of our number of petals
right because that that will give you
like it's the first petal so that's 0 or
and then like and then 1 out of 6 and
then 2 out of 6
2/6 etc i'm x 360 which is our number of
degrees so that's our rotation
so rotate and then path of petal is we
can just say I called it path look up so
up here I have
oh yeah path look up so path look up and
then
movies zero and the parental guidance of
that movie and finally the size of the
petals so size and we're using size
scale and for size is we said I am DB
reading some movies the first movie dot
rating cool oh and then I need to uh I
need to actually return that to
console.log petal data
oh look at that path is undefined
did something wrong but uh
oh yeah look so the rotation is right
0-60 120 and 180 240 300 and the size
should be the same because it's it's the
same movie so let's figure out what went
wrong with the path so path we said path
look up maybe I said paths look up no
path look up movie 0 PG why would that
be wrong path look up I don't have
enough pedals ha thank you so much so
let's see
yep into
No
yay so I have the pass and I have the
rotation and I have the size so I have
all of the data I need to make my path
or make my pedals so far does this all
sound good okay I'll take your silence
as a yes
and so now that we have the data and
then delete all my console logs all we
have to do is do the data data entered
the append from earlier so SVG dot
select all paths that data put in the
petal data dot enter dot append path so
that's the that's that's that's what we
talked about earlier data that entered
the pen and now if you actually inspect
if you inspect the Dom oh my god
you can see there's six paths that were
made just as we expected so let's do the
first thing and that is um the first
thing that we need for a path is the
path string and that's we set that on
the D attribute which I just realized I
never said I forgot to mention that
earlier so for to draw a path B all of
the path strings that we were doing
earlier with the the curves and then
lines and the move twos that needs to be
set on the D attribute of a path that
will probably have been important for me
to a mention so sorry about that and so
for the TA attribute what we want to do
is use the path that's been belt so D
that pal I look yeah we already have a
little like thing that's been drawn here
and then we want to actually before we
do that there any when you look up SVG
transforms so for the people that did
does anybody want to talk about it
briefly
the SVG transform
so it is basically you can apply these
transforms to any of the SVG elements
and the ones that I use the most often
is translate scale and rotate and they
do exactly what they sound like
so translate will move over that element
by an X Y position scale would be a
scale of one is a hundred percent and
scale of 0.5 would be fifty percent a
scale of two would be two hundred
percent etc oh and then it'd be if you
put in only one number then it will be
scaled to both direct both the x and y
direction but if you put in two numbers
then it'll be scaled to the x direction
and then the y direction and then you
have a rotation and you put in the angle
out of 360 so let's do that
um let's first do the translate
so if you notice right now this uh this
pedal is right here because that's my
zero zero there's absolutely no
translation um and if you notice I
actually start I think I Center all of
my petals at zero zero so the first
thing I want to do is move the pedals
over and so I'm just gonna say translate
100 100 oops 100 100 and that's just
like a random I'm just picking up random
magic numbers of 100 and 100 but I do
want to say very briefly that when I'm
translating something what's actually
happening is um you can think of it this
way so let's say we have an SVG and this
is zero zero um the the way that I like
to think about it is that when you set
the x and y coordinate of an SVG element
um whatever so basically everything um
let's say I draw this rectangle and this
is at 10 10 this 10 10 is relative to
the parent SVG so it's kind of like you
know how if you do like a div within a
div and then you set the outside div to
position:relative and you set the inside
div to position:absolute that's kind of
what's what happens with SVG naturally
so like that's like so that's like if
you did div is position:relative and
this is div is position:absolute it's
kind of like what's happening inside but
here's an interesting thing so right now
this one is X is equal to 10 y is equal
to 10
so like for this rectangle I'm saying X
is equal to 10 and Y is equal to 10 and
that's being position absolutely
relative to the parent SVG but if I do
want to translate then here's the
interesting thing if I do this rectangle
and I translate it ten to ten and I have
ice is 10 and Y is 10 something really
interesting happens which is that it
actually gets let's say this is 20 and
this is 20 it actually gets positioned
here this ends up with this isn't that
fascinating
okay so anybody have a guess why this
actually results in this so this is this
is 2020 anybody have a guess why this is
happening so the reason huh yeah exactly
so
hello ok so the reason why this is
happening is that when we do our
translations essentially we're saying
okay
like pretend that there's like this
pretend that this element has this like
invisible parent div and that parent div
has moved down to ten ten so instead of
four now now for this rectangle the new
coordinate system is now here
so this actually is the zero zero for
this rectangle now and then this is the
new ten ten for this rectangle with it
fascinating I love the translation No
okay I'm but I'm saying this only
because this will also come in handy and
when we're doing the next step we have
one more exercise after this so yeah
so essentially this is really helpful
because as you can imagine all of our
paths are relative to 0-0 like we've
defined all of these paths as like you
know like start at zero zero or at zero
50 or 50 0 or whatever and then it's
like curving to like 100 or something
it's still it's still got its own
coordinate system but when we use
transform and translate we don't
actually have to like you know make up
new numbers or anything we just have to
say translate 100 a hundred and then it
will basically shift the coordinate
system around so that yeah so that that
happens I'm okay so I'm not that great
at CSS I'm pretty sure this is how CSS
transforms work - is it true okay like
if you do CSS transforms in session mmm
yeah so let's translate it 100 100 and
then the next thing we want to do is we
want to rotate so previously we've
calculated our rotate so all we have to
do is use that we say d dot rotate oh oh
then I'm using our string literal so
dollar sign open bracket whoo did it and
you I mean did that happen for any of
you wait you haven't been typing along
or anything right okay sometimes
sometimes people type along and then
they're also like because that happens
for them and so yeah so that happens cuz
we will now rotate at all six petals and
then finally we want to scale so scale
and then we use what we've previously
calculated so that's D size and it just
gets scaled smaller
and then because I don't want it to be
filled I just say fill none and then
stroke I'm gonna say black that's it
how's that
and your part that you want me to
elaborate on do you have your own
flowers were you able to get your own
flowers mmm cool okay are you ready to
move on because it is I believe 436 and
so we have 24 minutes to make the rest
of the flowers are you ready to make the
rest of the flowers nope
was that you though okay wait let me ask
you this way so how we did we cover it
enough such that if you go back and look
at the code yourselves you'll be able to
get it or do you want me to elaborate on
any of the parts so that when you go
home and look at it yourselves you can
understand it because that's my goal
right now out of the 3 steps that we
talked about tell me about any of the
parts where it didn't feel quite
intuitive and you want me to cover again
the person that said no back there what
do you want me to elaborate on are you
sure it's fine okay are you ready to
move on oh oh there's okay yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah huh oh yeah yes please go do
that yeah
because you guys have been here in here
for the last three and a half hour
no three hours or so yeah I went to a
pee break though so I snuck out for that
and yeah yeah please go and then in that
case are you alright with it running
over a little bit yeah yeah a tiny bit
okay so five minutes relax go outside
and then we're gonna make the rest of
the flowers get back into it it is now
for 53 so I'm gonna try and finish up
thank you okay it is for 53 and we're
going to try and finish up the last few
part of the last part yeah thank you
okay so we're gonna try and finish up
the last part as quickly as we can and
that is to finish we're going to draw
the rest of the flowers and to do that
we need to be able to ness elements so
the nesting elements is basically like
we want to do that in SPG we want to do
that when we want to apply the same
styles and transforms to a group of
elements and so in the case of the
flowers basically we have a group
element in this case that consists of
both the petals and leaves and I've
applied the transform applied translate
and scales on them and then within them
I have the past that I make up the
petals and it just has a rotation apply
because the rotation is unique to the
petals whereas the
and the scale is applied to all the
petals so we can do the translation
scale on the group elements and we can
do the rotation on the path elements so
that's what we're gonna go for for it
and do and hopefully we'll be able to
finish before the 5:30 group picture and
the food so let's start out with Camden
and go through this as quickly as I can
so this is the next piece of code and
this is just shows you how to nest
element so essentially this is here's
the data set I'm and then we have a
group of G elements and a set of circles
on and within those group elements and
when that looks like is on Oh so as you
can see the data is there's a set of
circles that have a red fill and a set
of circles that have a blue show so
let's see how that's working
I'm an so at the very here and I'm using
I'm saying SVG select all groups and
most einie
and then so I'm using the SVG group
element and that's child elements
because in SVG Oh Mike HTML so with HTML
you know we'll be doing will like nest
all these different elements right we
can nest divs with in dibs we can nest
like paragraphs we can nest like spans
we can nest begin that's almost pretty
much everything we want with HTML right
and then you can like apply styles to
them or like you can translate things or
but within the SVG the only element that
you are allowed to nest children is the
group element so if you try to nest a
rectangle within a rectangle a circle
within a rectangle any of those
thing will happen like it will not work
only group elements can have things and
group elements can have group elements
and that stay within it and yeah so
group and group elements circles
rectangles and stuff you can that's all
of that within a parent group component
and so in this case what we're doing is
um we're saying the same data enter
append pattern as before and we're
saying I'm you know here's my set of
data and basically my data is that first
like combined that first object to my
first group and bind the second object
to the second group so then what I'm
doing is basically saying the first
group of the first data set or sorry the
first data object has a fill right and
so once I found that I'm using it in the
outer fill and then I'm returning d dot
fill and that's why previously you saw
all those circles have a red fill and
then the second one is um has a fill or
blue so then like back here you saw all
of these circles how to fill a blue so
that's what's happening yeah so this
gets created to groups and then down
here when we're doing the when we're
creating a circle for what we want to
create a bunch of circles for jeunesse
within their group I'm essentially what
I'm doing is for the circle as I say I'm
select all the circles in those groups
so they're groups that we just created
I'm select the circle within those
groups and then and for the data notice
here notice that I'm instead of passing
in a data into a data array like we did
before we're actually passing in a
function this is interesting and so I
like here when we're doing a data array
we're passing in a function what this is
saying is basically
with d3 if you create if you nest
elements and those nested on the the
children actually inherit the data of
the pant so what that's what's happening
here is it saying okay so here's the
here's the data that's already been
bound to the parents so this fill red
and a circle array tell me what tell me
the data array you want for the child
circles and so here what I'm doing is
I'm saying okay cool this data that's
been bound to the parent and for these
circles what I want is to use the array
of circles right so here I'm saying on
the circle array of two 2515 return that
so the child data is essentially this
like take that array of two 2550 and
return that and that's the data array
from my child circles and then we do the
senate same enter a pen oh yeah so we do
the data enter a pen and so here's
what's happening right so we're
basically saying here's the parent group
with the with the data and then we're
going to just grab the array the child
array and that's the new set of data and
that data gets mapped to the circles
that we want to enter so it's basically
like what we talked about before with a
data enter a pen except now instead of
you know like I'm having well okay yeah
so it's basically like before when we
had data enter a pen except now we're
inheriting some data that we can do
something with as long as we return an
array again because remember thought
data always always expects an array so
that's what's happening here
I'm and so all of this results in a
group container with a data that says
fill and circle and within there and we
have the circles that have those data
that data that data bound to it I let
the words out really fast
um do you want me to repeat should I
repeat that okay let me try repeating
that again really quickly okay let me
see if I can draw that really quick
so I have two objects the first one has
filled is bright and then let's call
this just child and that child has an
array to 2550 fill blue child
10 100 150 so when they bind this data
or when I use this data set it creates
two group elements right and then this
is this red one gets bound to this and
this blue one gets bound to the second
one now the fun thing is when we try to
create any child elements to this so
like now if we say okay like this
selection of groups now try to create
any children like let's say the children
are the circles these children actually
get they actually inherit the the data
that's been balanced to the parent
so they actually inherit this data and
they will also be able to say they will
also know oh I am like fill red so blue
but I'm because we want to make a circle
for each one of these child arrays we
just say okay actually give me back for
the selection of circles and I want to
create a circle for every element in the
child array so that's why we're
returning the child and then we're
saying I want this to be applied to this
one that's to be applied to this one and
this to be applied to this one and then
for the second for the second group I
want this here this here and
here but that's what's happening that's
a lot of lights so yes so we're saying
for its children I want to use this
array of data to create my children
elements okay and then so the last thing
we want to do is make all the flowers
and this might sound like a lot of work
but it's actually a very very minimal
work now that we've created one flower
since you go from one flower to many
flowers is actually very little work and
[Applause]
I'm just gonna go straight into it yeah
okay so set the main four scales is the
same as before
I'm just gonna copy that over
and then number two is now instead of
creating data for the petals now we need
to create a group for each flower right
and then we need to translate and scale
those flowers so let's do that so we
have let's call each of those flowers
let's call that selection of group
elements flowers and we say SVG not
select all group
and then the the data in this case is
the array of movies right because each
flower is equal to each movie so we do
the movie or data is movies oh yeah if
you want to type long ooh
movies enter dot append and append
groups now if we inspect element if we
inspect the sweetie we'll see like a few
hundred group elements that have been
made or we should that seems like okay
so now we've created all the group
elements we've created a group element
for each movie and then right now let's
just apply the translate and scale so
transform is what the attribute is
called and then what I want to do is
pass in both the data and index big and
for the X I'm just gonna say I believe
so index mod to me so I'm just going to
help be on each row so mod three times
uh it's just yeah let's just uh move
them over by no but let's move him over
by
I think it's yeah let's move them over
by I'm going to move them over by 200
and then I'm off me plus 0.5 which just
means like just move them over by 1/2 uh
and then um for the Y basically math top
floor I into PI by 3 so basically
whatever my index is divided by 3 and
that's the road that I'm on and again
this is just so just do those 0.5 times
200 and then I want to do the scale
transform so that was scale is equal to
a size scale and then we pass in the
rating yes the reading for that movie
and now will we return translate x
translate X Y and scale
yeah thank you and then nothing you
should show up but now you'll see for
each of the groups you'll see their
translate and the scale
okay now we have the flowers so let's
make even at the petals for each bar
so now instead of selecting them from
the SVG we want to select them from the
flowers so basically instead of looking
instead of working within the SVG
container now we want to work within
each of the flower groups as our parent
container so for each flower select all
the path elements that are going to be
our petals and then here's a bumper so
um if you want to you are more than
welcome to do let's do it this way so
dot data
let's first console.log oh yeah
that's just the first console long and
see what happens and as you can see when
they call us a lot here it's the it's
the data from the movie it's it's the
data that's been bound to the parent
flower group container and so what we
want is like we did before we want to
use this movie data to create the right
number of petals right and rotate them
accordingly so use this to use this data
so now we want to say numb petals is
equal two of them
it was enough thank you num puddle scale
and then now we use d dot foot know if
we do mum petals so still 6s any sense
and now we want to return return the
array of petals right now we want to
return the array of petals so I'm still
being x so six petals and then now now
all I want to do is the rotation i /
numpy dole's times 360 same as before
and then the right path so it was path
pads
lookup and we use d dot thank you but i
need to do i need to add in here breast
of the pencil
cool so diva peachy thank you and now
let's see if we have the right number of
petals being made for each of the groups
enter the Ovid didn't enjoy that thank
you
you are saving me right now
yay yeah I try opening them up see all
six right no okay except yeah so now the
paths are being made for each of the
flowers so now we only have a few more
steps so so we need to set the attribute
for the path so the D attribute for the
paths for each of the petals and then we
also need to rotate them that's it so
let's do that let's first rotate them so
transform D turn up rotate d dot rotate
and then add er a deep return D doctor
oh yeah did that happen for you that's
it right now we just need to do actually
tied to something really awesome and
which was that you said Waylon I'm gonna
say Phil Nunn and then tell me what was
the for their strokes you do something
where you used the color scale so
there's you is it just here you also say
color
ooh do you three that interpolate
rainbow and they should do that I divide
by non petal skin cool and then GG choke
with pie yeah so we're better than the
black great yes all the colors all the
colors and you even did a blend mode
that style was a blend mode then it does
not mix okay let me explain mode and
multiply yeah no hey I make that bigger
yeah no just showing off
I'm not showing off tie it's showing off
does that make you happy to see me happy
actually let's try actually doing it as
a fill instead of this photo
oh this makes me happy
okay not rainbow at the end makes all
the difference okay so I'm gonna put
this into the complete code see so that
you can take a look items with of course
their rainbow oh my chuckles all the
rainbows meryl streep uh type its his
brilliance look at all of that and I
really sincerely hope that you got
something like this too and I knew that
three and a half hours is still like not
that much time to like you know we get
all cover all of that we did today but
hopefully um it helps you get at least a
little bit familiar with SVG pods and
with the basics of d3 and then hopefully
you got some pretty flowers out of it
I'm and if you are really proud of your
flowers and I hope you are I really
really want to see them so please like
screenshot them and tweet them to me
and my handle is this is my handle right
here please tweet me so I can be really
really proud of my initials my initials
are surely still Musa as X Y W you I
actually made the handle without
realizing the implementations of my
initials and then my my ta at the time
was like surely really and I'm like what
are you talking about just like your a
handle your github handle and I was like
what about it just like we did a lot and
I was like I was like crap and that was
like seven years ago and I have now
fully embraced it so if you need to just
remember it as this sexy without the
ease and if that makes it easier for you
to tweet me your flowers then so be it
so thank you so much for joining today
thank you so much for all the funds and
the the participation and the rainbows
and I hope you have a great rest of the
conference
yeah
[Applause]